the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
in this video i will show you what i
believe are some of the best scenes from
the second season of the show as you all
know game of thrones was famously known
for delivering some of the greatest
moments in television history almost
every one of those amazing moments would
happen at the end of the season moments
like the execution of ned stark the red
wedding the death of jon snow as well as
just about every major battle now as
much as we all love those scenes we also
know those are not the only great
moments in game of thrones after i
finish making all of these videos i will
have shown you some of the best moments
from each and every episode of the
series now let me show you what i think
are the best scenes from this season
season 2 episode 1 jaime gets a visit
from robin greywind now this is still an
amazing scene even after knowing how
everything unfolds this was back when
all of the fans were united in hating
jaime lannister it was so satisfying
because he was no longer sitting on his
high horse looking down on everyone else
finally a stark was looking down at him
as he was all alone sitting in the mud
what makes this scene even better though
is what rob stark says to him during
their interaction
you think my father's going to negotiate
with you
you don't know him very well
no
he's starting to know me
three victories don't make you a
congress
[Music]
it's better than three defeats
jaime most likely never saw himself
ending up in a situation like this hemi
and his father had the bigger army him
and his father had far more experience
in the field of battle and even if we're
looking at man vs man jaime is by far
the better swordsman as you all know
he's actually considered as one of the
greatest swordsmen in all of westeros
yet here he was held captive by a boy
who was exceeding everyone's
expectations
and right before the scene ends he is
reminded that he is now at the mercy of
rob stark
season 2 episode 2 lore tyrion sends
jenno slint on vacation
this is without a doubt my favorite
scene from the episode i also think this
is when tyrion lannister's character was
at his best this was back when he was
smarter than almost everyone else it was
as if every word that fell out of his
mouth was sharper than valyrian steel
are you drunk
not have my honor questioned by an imp
i'm not questioning your honor lord
janice
i'm denying its existence
you think i'll stand here and take this
from you dwarf dwarf
you should have stopped at him he was
obviously enjoying himself when he was
standing in as the hand of the king for
his father after he arrived in king's
landing he almost immediately got rid of
lord janos slint there's nothing better
than watching tyrion send the
backstabbing baby murdering scumbag to
the night's watch now that i think of it
there is actually one scene better than
this however that scene is from season 5
when jon snow finally takes his head off
his shoulders oh how i missed the days
when we would get scenes like this when
lore tyrion lannister and braun showed
up and let everyone know there was a new
sheriff in king's landing we shall hear
what joffrey has to say about this no we
shan't
season 2 episode 3 urine sacrifice
there were many great moments in the
episode but i ultimately had to go with
this one because joran actually
sacrificed himself because he would not
hand over gendry to the lannister
soldiers you gotta respect that because
joran could have avoided this if that's
what he wanted he could have left arya
in king's landing with the lannisters
annie could have handed gendry over but
he did what he thought was right even if
it meant giving up his own life
unfortunately this scene is an
afterthought for most fans because joran
wasn't a main character but the north
remembers this is your last chance
in the name of king joffrey
drop your weapons
i don't think i will
now there is one other thing that makes
this scene even better this is also when
arya saves jack and nagar from burning
alive as you all know since arya saved
jack and nagar and the other men he now
owed her three lives this would result
in arya and jack agar sharing several
great scenes at harrenhal and it would
ultimately lead arya to learning the
skills that she would later use to kill
walter frey and even the night king
season 2 episode 4 a shadow is born now
this was another one of those moments
that let us all know we were not
watching an ordinary show melisandre's
shadow baby set a new standard for what
the f did i just see happen in game of
thrones the birth of the dragons was
this amazing magical moment but the
birth of this shadow baby was somewhat
frightening
this also let us know that maybe
melisandre isn't all smoke and mirrors
after all
maybe she does have some sort of magical
abilities season 2 episode 5 the lion
and the wolf i almost went with the
shadow baby again because this is the
episode where it stabs renly baratheon
however as insane as that scene was i
still think there is one better this is
the episode where we begin to get one of
the many amazing moments with arya stark
and tywin lannister it's almost a shame
these characters were not on the same
side because the chemistry they had
together in their scenes was incredible
this is actually one of dan and dave's
better ideas because these scenes don't
happen in the books now what makes the
scene even better is what arya says
they say he can't be killed
do you believe them
no
my lord
anyone can be killed
this just goes to show you how fearless
she could be not only was she surrounded
by lannister soldiers but she was also
staring right in the face of evil and
never flinched season 2 episode 6 theon
greyjoy loses his way again this is
another amazing episode with a lot of
great scenes but i don't think there is
a better one than this right here now i
know there are a lot of fans who hate
theon greyjoy but i don't think you can
deny the actor's ability to sell his
scenes this was also a very big moment
for the story as you all know house
stark was the main family we were
focusing on throughout the show and this
was essentially the final act that would
send the rest of them scattering into
the wind for many seasons to come
not only did he force bran and rickon to
run but this would ultimately cause
winterfell to wind up in the hands of
ramsay snow let's help you fian greyjoy
now you are truly lost
what really sent the scene over the edge
for me is how it ended those last words
from sir rodrick had to haunt theon for
the rest of his days
season 2 episode 7 the wildling and the
wolf here we have one of the many great
scenes john and egret share in this
episode alone as a matter of fact their
characters were the main focus of this
episode because they had the most amount
of scenes so i felt like it was only
right to highlight one of them what
makes all of these scenes even better is
knowing these characters eventually do
fall in love in real life not only did
they fall in love but they are now
married and they even recently
celebrated having their first child
together their on-screen chemistry
together is off the charts and it will
become even more glaring once you see
jon scenes with danny what i think makes
this scene so great is what yeegart says
to jon right before it ends
i have the blood of the first men my
ancestors lived here same as yours
so why are you fighting nose
i believe this is the first step of jon
snow understanding the wildling
situation
his eyes will only continue to open up
even more from here on out as you all
know john will eventually make an
alliance with the wildlings allowing
them through the wall at castle black a
decision that will ultimately get him
killed season 2 episode 8 the stark boys
are alive this is easily one of the most
uplifting moments from the season now i
don't know how many of you actually
thought theon killed the stark boys but
i remember i thought he did after i saw
those burnt and blackened bodies as if
how stark hadn't lost enough already
when bran and rickon went missing then
theon revealed those dead bodies i
thought we were only a handful of
seasons away from seeing all of how
stark get executed one by one i think
this was a much needed moment of relief
for fans of hal stark
they mustn't know
brown would blame himself
they'll never hear it from me
[Music]
now if you're one of those fans who
hates bran stark you might look at this
scene a little differently in hindsight
however i still think it's the best
scene from the episode
season 2 episode 9 the black water burns
i can still remember exactly the way i
felt when i saw this episode for the
first time i remember feeling so lost
because i could not decide who i wanted
to win on one hand i wanted stannis to
take over the city and flush out the
lannisters i wanted joffrey cersei and
her father dead but i was also worried
about what would happen if stannis did
win would that mean sansa and tyrion
would die i was afraid they would either
way i was very excited for the episode
nonetheless i love when the hound and
bra nearly kill each other i love when
the hound says f the king i also love
the moment he has in sansa's room and i
even like the scene where tyrion and
lord varus have a moment right before
the battle now with all of that being
said i think the moment that stands out
the most is when the wildfire engulfs
the blackwater bay
it was absolutely incredible and i
believe it was the first of many big
spectacles game of thrones would deliver
season 2 episode 10 the army of the dead
marches on now if the wildfire burning
on the blackwater bay was game of
thrones first big spectacle this was
without a doubt its second this was when
we got our first actual look of not only
the white walkers but the massive army
of the dead as well we only saw glimpses
of them in the opening episode of the
first season we basically only saw a
shadow holding ahead however this scene
showed us what the white walkers looked
like in all of their glory and it was
absolutely horrifying i had never seen
anything like this before and it was
scenes like this that ultimately made me
so fascinated with all of the different
mysteries of the north this was one hell
of a scene to end the second episode
i thought the white walkers were
definitely marching on the wall in the
following season now we all know how
things unfolded after this scene we
would not see them again until much
later let me know what some of your
favorite scenes are from this season do
you agree with the ones i named here or
do you think i should have added
something else leave me your thoughts
down below also let me know what some of
your favorite scenes are from season
three maybe they will be in the next one
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching my video i hope i see you back
here for my video of season three have a
great day everyone i will see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you